[Music]
we're gonna take you along a little bit
of our journey today of getting to the
cloud and building applications in the
cloud at Global Payments and how we're
using looker and bigquery to scale up
around the world for an application that
we've built just a little background
Global Payments large payment processor
headquartered in Atlanta Georgia for
billion in net revenue last year if you
don't know much about us about 220 2.5
million customers that we've given some
sort of payment solution to around the
world and about 11,000 employees is the
size of our company we have it we have a
strategy at Global Payments it's about
software driven partnered solutions
around the world an omni-channel
experience you've seen that in some of
the presentations around here we want to
make sure that we can deliver things
across multiple channels around the
world and get into faster growth markets
one of the ways we're gonna expand those
markets is going to the cloud probably
about a couple years ago our chief
product officer Frank Young had a
mission he wanted to create a
best-in-class engagement platform not
not a bi platform not just a reporting
platform but something that attracted
customers created stickiness and was
something that we could be proud of at
Global Payments so he partnered with us
and about that same time our CIO Guido
Saki put us on a cloud first strategy at
Global Payments he knew that we need to
have a multi cloud cloud first strategy
to deliver things around the world we
had to have reduced total cost of
ownership we couldn't do things on Prem
you've heard that theory many different
places so he launched us on that that
strategy we needed to build the
technology solutions that our customers
would like around the world we needed a
platform that could we could innovate on
and deliver new products every every
year every quarter to drive business and
we need to do it securely and safely in
the cloud you've heard a lot of things
about security and Google cloud but
those were really the driving
there's that launched us on this this
journey that we've been on I don't know
where all of you are in your journey so
I'll review a little bit this is a
couple years ago we started to take a
look at different vendors different
things we enlisted the help of our
architecture department led by Ollie
flaws to look at some of these factors
to help us out probably you guys had
these same factors but I'll review them
we needed not just a bi tool everybody
seems to have one two three of them bi
tools Network for the mass markets we
needed something that could provide
embedded BI in that engagement platform
we're talking about we needed RESTful
API enables everybody out here is
probably trying to produce API is trying
to get out there where people can code
to your API rather than us have to code
for them out there we needed something
with responsive design every everybody
in here has a different device a
different modem of connecting we need to
make sure that that platform was able to
be displayed on any device visually
repealing to anybody that wanted to do
business with Global Payments we needed
a powerful abstraction layer so that
when we change data that changes very
readily out there we can put something
in between that's where we use the
looker platform and we'll get to that
later in there and we needed to
integrate with a clout we evolved
evaluated many different cloud vendors
too we chose the multiple cloud strategy
we got that but for this application we
chose Google cloud platform we needed
something that could power a data like
data sking you got to have data to do
anything these days we needed we
evaluate things on the technology now
and where we thought things were going
in the future you have to look forward a
little bit things changes very fast out
there every day we the total cost of
ownership was a big factor for how we
wanted to produce our applications in
the cloud Security's number one we're a
payment processor if we don't keep your
credit card number safe and all your
personal data safe we're out of business
so we needed to use that as a guiding
principle and a data center region
availability everybody's heard of gdpr
india's put some rules in lately the
word you may have to put your applique
locally you may have put your data
locally so forward-thinking this has
allowed us to take some of those factors
into account why we chose Google cloud
platform and looker out there again a
GCP looker bigquery and App Engine are
the main components Jason's gonna walk
you through the design and the pieces we
used to get to the platform that we're
rolling out we needed a customer first
design one of the things that we learned
over time was you must listen to the
customer you guys have all probably
heard it but we actually used my team
plus some partners to build a prototype
almost two years ago that we launched
out to the customers we got feedback
back in January of 18 hour design team
led by Claire Bowden out of Ireland
redesign this thing listen to the
customer in January of 18 we really
started building this out for the
customers we went to beta in the summer
and we have been getting feedback from
the from the customers and I'll tell you
where our journey has gone to a little
bit later we needed an API enabled again
if we cannot enable an API for our
customers because we serve everybody
from the small mom-and-pop to the
medium-sized guy with four franchises to
the Verizon's of the world so this
architecture that Jason is going to talk
about services all of those customers
again any device anywhere and then we
want to make sure that we could launch
on an analytics platform Google bigquery
and a lot of the things that GCP that
you're hearing around all these sessions
could provide and we knew what enhance
our offering to all of our customers our
custom-built
application looks a little like this and
I'll go into it a little bit more after
Jason gives you a little more than nuts
and bolts of the architecture but we
need to scale to any enterprise we need
to scale to your your mom and dad may
have their small business it needs to be
useful for them needs to be useful for
the medium guy and the large guy needs
to be extensible to any platform and
highly customizable because it has to be
one size fits all for our users what I'd
like to show you now is if you could
switch to demo one yes
hold on
this is where a demo there we go can you
switch the demo one there you go this is
a little marketing video that our team
has put together the portal that we're
launching
built on top of GCP with the components
that Jason's gonna describe and I'll let
him get up here and talk about it but
this is a portal design for everybody in
our around the world that we do business
with today to get the information about
the transactions week process for them
looks pretty slick in my opinion I think
our design team has done a great job but
I'll let Jason tell you a little bit
about how we built that cool thanks mark
so like Mark said we've kind of went on
this journey probably about two years
ago we started you know we kind of got
the we decided we're gonna go all in on
the cloud which is a pretty big change
for us and can you guys go back to
slides there we go so I'm gonna talk a
little bit of what we actually built
here so obviously it's a modern web
application it's it's designed
completely in react
everything's hosted in GCP we went with
a micro service architecture as everyone
is doing nowadays that gives us some
extensibility most and you know the
application there's a lot of things but
I think the most important thing that
we're here to talk about today is how
we're getting this data from our data
Lake to the customers and you know it's
a little non-conventional here but what
we're actually going with is streaming
this data from bigquery itself to the
customer in real time there's no
reporting layer in between there you
know we're not doing any pre
aggregations that you would typically it
seems like a lambda architecture or
something like that
so you know pretty standard web
application what I want to focus on
today is the reporting API which is how
we're actually getting this down as Mark
alluded to it bigquery and look are our
keys to that so let me start with them
what our goals was for this right so we
have some disparate data sources some
things come in batch at the end of the
damp sure a lot of you have that we also
have some stuff that comes in real-time
so there's there's a challenge there you
can't go with with kind of like a batch
layer where you process it nightly
because we have streaming data coming in
at the same time so obviously that's a
challenge there's been solutions to do
I don't know if you guys heard of the
lamda architecture where you'll kind of
take your batch layer you'll take your
streaming your kind of amalgamate them
in an in a API layer and serve that up
to the customer that was one option the
other thing we need to do is is we want
you know some self-service right in
previous lives of this application we
found ourselves having lots and lots of
different reports that our team would
have to customize and in design they're
really just permutations around other
stuff so we would love to give some self
service to the customer and let them
kind of say I want this column I want
that column and you know you'll see
where that comes in
the the third thing is you know we want
it relatively fast this will you'll kind
of see as we get in this is the biggest
challenge to this architecture of going
directly to bigquery is getting that
speed to to web level right web speed
and then obviously fault tolerance right
when you're going through and you're
building the data link you really don't
want to you want to be able to start
from scratch
right you want to be able to go back in
and rebuild the entire thing it's kind
of the mindset of the whole Map Reduce
you know you have the data lake and you
want to be able to rebuild that from
scratch if your design changes they
aggregates change anything like that
right I need to be able to go back and
start from scratch and not have you know
basically an immutable data set at the
end of the day so with those goals what
we've entered a building is a reporting
framework that kind of lives on what
we're calling a multi-layered data link
so you can start with the the you know
the regular batch data comes in files
we're throwing all that into GCP storage
buckets from there we move on we
essentially move it as is to bigquery
one-for-one right and we're calling that
our trusted layer this is kind of our
Global Payments these are not industry
standard terms this is what internally
we are calling these layers so the
trusted layer is pretty much straight in
from a one-for-one like for like from
the data set and then we'll go through
and we'll put some metadata on it we'll
protect sensitive data that you know
we're not going to persist things that
shouldn't be persistent
at that point we move it to a second
layer which is also in bigquery so these
are bigquery to bigquery jobs and that's
what we're calling the transform layer
so this is where we're gonna put some
data quality rules out we're going to go
ahead and normalize things like dates
data types right get that data in in a
clean state where you can put other
tools on top of it whether it be you
know eventually a IML right that that
will come off the transform later this
is our normalized kind of data quality
now I can always go back and rebuild
that from the bucket to the trusted to
the transformed the key I think to this
design though is really we'll work on
the consumption layer and and this is
kind of equivalent to a Bachelor in in
in a more traditional Big Data
architecture all the consumption layer I
think of the consumption there almost
like a materialized view this is where
we can take multiple data sources that
came in from the transform later
aggregate them together flatten them out
run metrics on it if we have some common
luck KPIs or any aggregations that we
want to run we put them in the
consumption layer the problem is you
know then how do you get that to the
application right I really don't want
all my applications writing directly to
bigquery especially from the internet so
this is where we have our consumer
systems which is you can see up there
this is looker and what we're using
looker as is really that abstraction
layer to our data link got a little
slide here and look here look who's
giving us a lot of stuff so does anybody
familiar with looker if you're not the
platform itself is really just it's a
it's its own modeling language really
XML based where you can basically define
a contract and put the data behind the
scenes and looker wilt will go ahead and
form the query up and return the data
back to you this helped us a lot because
when we're building this application we
also came at it from two prongs right we
were building the web application in the
reporting layer and the data warehouse
the data lake all those letters at the
same time so what we did was look ER is
we basically use liquor as a contract
right the the model that we defined in
liquor we might have stubbed some
it out now the the front-end team who's
building the api's can start coding
against that why the backend ETL teams
are actually fulfilling the data sets
behind the scenes and if we need to
change anything we change it at that one
place that kind of gets to the idea of
the consistent no matter matter who's
looking into this data if it's going
through our looker model everyone's
gonna get it exactly the same
look our also offers an API which is key
to this kind of design so they have a
very robust API where I can do filtering
column selection things like that
anything that's in my model I can
essentially query through the API they
almost have an API first mentality so I
don't have to write sequel from my
coding where I can use looker just like
another API data API it just happens to
have bigquery behind the scenes look are
also gives us visualizations so there
are embedded visualizations you see kind
of on the screen right there you know
you have the little the charts and
graphs those are all driven from looker
from the exact same model that we get
the data from which is you know we--you
it really helps in the development
efforts I don't have to do any extra
development to get a pie chart around
the same data that I already have I just
basically configure a what that's called
a look I call that I can embed that in
my application you'll see that later
March is going to show a little bit more
of the app paging so another thing we do
directly in the looker model so some of
this data is huge and we're not going to
serve up through an API you know 10
million records coming back so I can
actually get paging and looker takes
care of doing the the limits for me
behind the scenes it's completely
abstracted from me I can just say here's
the data I want I want page 6 it'll tell
me how many come back the other key
force was export right one of our
requirements is some of our customers
like to take this data from the portal
put it into you know their own
accounting system or so you know rather
than have to go through and write an
export system to do this there is export
functionalities built-in and looker we
essentially just proxy him straight
through
so let me talk a little bit about what
we built but I'm gonna have to use the
mouse here to point to some of this so
what we really did here was we built an
API layer on top of the liquor API we
kind of extended it a little bit it
served a couple of purposes the first
thing was our application is it is a spa
right it's a react application he uses
JWT s obviously i have to have something
to convert that JWT into looker so our
custom API that proxies over to looker
is handling the security from the JWT
turning into the looker model but the
other thing that we did that I think is
the key to this is we built a little
metadata engine on top of looker so if
you see the API layer in here well you
basically what happens is just a mouse
there we go yeah see that ok so you know
all of our app is really just html5
react compiled ounce put in a storage
bucket load balance through cloud load
balancing right boom there's your html5
web application all the magic happens
here in the API layer so pretty much the
the JavaScript for mirror is making Ajax
calls directly to the various micro
services the one we really care about
here is is the let's this reporting API
right here so what this guy does is
we've persisted the metadata around the
looker model into a sequel so this guy
can actually go look up all of the
different available columns in cloud
sequel for you right cuz I get I know
who you are from the token I can go say
you know what what queries what reports
do you want and essentially that's just
some custom storage that we've done and
then this guy just runs a Builder
pattern and proxies over whatever that
request was to the looker API which in
turn generates the bigquery sequel
returns it back proxies it back to the
front-end into a standard JSON format
this is really anybody familiar with
open-closed principle well this is done
essentially has allowed us to
extend this with really writing no code
I can build another looker model I can
put it into our configuration database
that could point to any data I want and
expose it through this application
through this API with a configuration
only I have to write the look ml which
is the the abstraction layer I obviously
have to have the data but I don't have
to do any additional code besides
enabling it in my metadata layer for the
customer to get it or the portal to get
it so now as we extend and you go from
those hundred reports if I end up with a
new request I can build a new looker
model I can put it in to the app and the
security is actually put on the model
layer so you might see a little later
the report builder which kind of gives
us some self-service as well so we
actually allow folks to come in and
customize what they want this to look
like so they can go into our Web API
using the metadata and say there's 700
columns available here I care about
these six and I want to sort by these
and I want to filter by these will
persist that in cloud sequel and
essentially that just builds a it's a
builder pattern right it's just a
straight proxy to looker so as long as
we have the looker model I don't even
want to know how many permutations we
could get but it's flexible we provide
some out-of-the-box stuff but the
customer can actually take the out of
the box they can modify it they can save
it they can share it with their
co-workers they can share it with other
people and that's all facilitated from
the reporting layer the other big thing
that I think we need to talk about here
you know you know the title of the
session is how we scaled this everything
in here is completely scalable through
GCP so the API layers all live in an app
engine right now we may move that to gke
that seems like the logical progression
when we started this that wasn't a thing
looker is actually we're not using
hosted by look or worse self hosting
looker
inside Auto scale VMs so we can expand
that out as much as we want and
obviously bigquery is as bigquery right
you can do as much as you want with that
we're on a you know there's a couple of
pricing miles on there's fixed cost and
then there's page you go we're on a
fixed cost for that security so
one of the challenges to that we really
need it to do is I the goal here is have
one API and based upon your token I only
return your data right so we have all of
the data in here the personas that use
this application everything from that
single merchants who might have one
location to maybe a regional manager
that has a hundred locations to maybe
our own internal customer support people
that service the entire portfolio so we
really wanted to ensure that that the
security trimming was done at the data
layer so what we're actually doing is as
we provision users in this application
we're using the cloud pub/sub and we're
actually pushing the data access ID so
it's just location IDs we call merchants
IDs but think of it like individual
locations and we push them to bigquery
and in looker itself we join to the
table informant is is to the point where
it can handle someone having two hundred
thousand you know a customer support
person might have access to two three
hundred thousand locations we actually
security trim that right in the layer so
when you pass over the liquor query
you're only getting back your data which
is fantastic we don't have to manage
that at the API layer we keep track of
it we pub/sub it out and we persist it
to bigquery and we do a join on the data
to right there get the the constraints
which is I don't know if anybody's ever
experienced that that's a huge problem
to solve big queries been a lifesaver
for that most are you know relational
systems could not handle joining on
something that big some are talked about
the omni-channel right another key to
this is we're just looking at the
merchant portal the application we built
it's really just the first consumer of
this this reporting API that we built
can you we could stick Apogee in front
of this give it an API key throw it to a
developer and the developer developer
can get the same access to the exact
same data you know you don't have to
play the describe this game everything
is going through a single channel which
guarantees that you're getting the same
better no matter what from a single
source so and I kind of alluded to the
performance you can probably expect that
that's probably the biggest you know
we've solved most of the other
challenges honor design goals the two to
three seconds that you saw earlier was
kind of what our product team wanted to
strive to that's the biggest challenge
in this but we've come a long way so
when we started this what 18 months ago
roughly since then last year and out
some custom partitioning for bigquery we
have applied that right so putting in
partitioning lowering your the this the
set of data that you're actually praying
against has improved time significantly
and we've we've actually applied that on
every single call so every single model
that we have has a primary date that we
have set in bigquery as the date
partition and we require the API calls
to pass in some kind of range all right
I can't let you go through the whole
data set so I think the max you can go
back is maybe two years it is a filter
you can say I can take seven days thirty
days yesterday specific date but we have
to constrain the data set so you're not
looking at the whole you know lifetime
of the data model the other thing that
we've been experimenting with and has
been I think it's gonna have some huge
progress as nested repeated I talked
about we have different disparate data
sources right well some of those kind of
fit together in kind of a hierarchical
pattern right you have this this concept
of of a batch when you're doing credit
cards inside that there may be multiple
transactions
well nested repeated is a great way
instead of doing a traditional RDBMS
right you can actually put those
transactions as a column inside bigquery
as another nested table and there's
there's an unnecessary well and it's
lightning-quick
so we're we're migrating we're
experimenting a little bit with moving
our consumption layer a little bit more
two nested repeat it and see if we can
get some performance improvements so far
it looks really promising the last thing
that I'll just mention is the you know
widen flat right the less joins you have
to do the the wider it's calmer so I
think most of our models are around six
to eight hundred columns and we're
exposing all of those in in Arkin
sumption lair right where we've
aggregated the different datasets
together or you go flat and wide and
disparate that's fine leave them null
you only get what you asked for back
from bigquery right so if you're only
asking for these eight columns
you're only gonna go through that the
data sets only going to Prue's eight
columns you don't you know you can have
that as wide as you why there's a I'm
sure there's a physical limit but I
don't think we've reached it that helps
when you're when you're looking at
perform it's like you can do these
aggregations on the fly you can join
them together but what we found is by
flattening that out the consumption
layer and having our looker model point
to the flatten table you get much better
improve it
okay so here's some real-world examples
this is just from partitioning properly
all right you know we started out these
are five different kind of reports that
we've enabled through that everyone gets
you can see in here two X's is the worst
we did just from partitioning some of
them got to ten X you can kind of see a
correlation between data processed and
time right this is the key first I think
is always apply a partition in every
query you're doing especially if you're
going to expose this out in real time
I'm hoping the nest didn't repeat it can
get these even further and you know
we're probably averaging in the
five-second range right now
you think about it it's still pretty
impressive when you're perusing an
entire you know petabyte data like in
real time I think that's all I got
Mark's gonna show you some actual slides
of the app thank you thanks JD so what
we're talking about that what I want to
go over is a little bit of the app
because like I said we started on this
journey we've been on it for quite a few
quite a few months with some partners
and my internal team building this app
this is what it looks like one of the
one of the keys like JD said this is the
look and feel those top visualizations
come out of that model they come out of
bigquery although we can get seven ten
thirty days two years with the data out
of there come through that API layer the
cool part about that too is I may have
different business partners I have a
bank in Canada that just wants me to
send them a visualization from our data
Lee
they don't people don't want to report
don't want things like that other people
just won an API and they want us to give
them the data if I want to settle and
I'm a developer I want to get that so
when they log into the portal they'll
see their data here if they have their
developer develop against our API book
that we're putting out there they're
gonna get the same data if I ship this
visualization off to another portal and
let somebody put it in their portal and
display it it is the same data because
bigquery and that architecture the JD
has shown you allow you to do that the
reason I showed you the demo earlier is
we're starting we're starting to roll
this this portal is is reality is going
out these are the reports we found that
a lot of the reports you make and JD
alluded to it how many people build
systems where you built a report and
that guy needs this column the other guy
needs a different column and all of a
sudden you end up with just a ton of
reports because bigquery allows us to
put all those columns out there allows
us to get that this is the set of
reports that we have for a worldwide
audience right now and we're rolling it
out it's not the hundred permutations
you used to have what we've what we
found here is those visualizations again
come through that the looker API from
bigquery we've built a custom report tab
down here and this I think is part of
the pretty cool design some of our
partners and some of our design team
came up with what some of this is those
columns are down that those come from
the same API
they've been delivered and that what you
can do is I talked about before we have
to service everybody from the small
mom-and-pop to the big guy this little
custom report thing here is kind of what
I've called the iPhone of reporting it
allows you to take on and remove and add
sort any of the columns on that report
so when we hit that that API and get all
the day we're grabbing all the data it's
there it's instantaneous so I can put
and remove things from this this portal
as we go and that way I don't have to
make 200 versions of a report it's all
sitting there all coming through that
same architecture from one database
in the background pretty cool I think so
here's the fun part I showed you the
marketing video because this is rolling
out today we have gone we have gone to
pilot in the UK and we have a worldwide
rollout strategy over the next three
months kind of interesting that we're
here it's like we're rolling out and
we're here on stage talking so it's kind
of fun but well we guys we had a multi
region migration we've started to
consolidate applications across the
enterprise and we actually Hadoop make
that some people think it's new we think
it's old we've actually retiring our
Hadoop infrastructure that our finance
folks were working on we have started to
consolidate with performance of bigquery
in the GCP platform kind of had that
kind of any tool mentality - we've been
able to put different tools up against
this looker other BI tools that we have
announced let's face it we all have them
you all might have tableau MicroStrategy
Business Objects they're loose against
this platform and we're allowing people
to use them we've let our data
scientists get in there we actually with
the backing of our CIO did a few ml
projects this year we went against the
same data using some of the products at
GCP Google has out there you know
typical ones the the easy ones or
attrition model you do a trishal
modelling around the world against the
same data that's out there for the for
the portal it's coming through the API
is all those our internal customers have
found it very very useful because now it
used to be the data within all these
different systems now you got this thing
called bigquery that I can and that data
like that I can dump it all into that
they can they don't always have to come
and ask for that one extra column or
this data storage as we all know in the
cloud is pretty cheap we store
everything that's the premise of the
data like right so now nobody's looking
for that additional column when we need
that additional column like we showed
you on a report it's there because the
technology architecture that JD talked
about works it's going live for us and
some of the external applications that
are out there we will be able to as we
get that book of api's launched through
Apogee will be able to allow to give
people that book of api's and let them
hit-the hit-the thing directly here's
our rollout plan like I said we're
scaling up to the world here's the title
of the here's the title of the
presentation right we we've been through
you eighty we have our regions around
the world we really talked about four
regions US UK Canada and the AP we're
rolling out our plan and we're doing our
load testing we'll have ten thousand
users on this April rolling to twenty
five in May will have a full forty
thousand on by June and as we go through
the year and we migrate our other
divisions on there and see the adoption
come forward we anticipate having the
full hundred hundred thousand to 120
thousand users on this platform
hopefully by the end of the year reason
we think that and I'm just kind of
pulling this out I've anonymized this
but like I says our design team has done
a great job my team has done a great job
delivering this our partners have done a
great job working with us to get this
out here but these are a few of the
reviews and our old portals we designed
them for us they worked but this is the
first time when I look at this and we
get we get people that are that have
actually looked at this thing and says
you know what from different personas
different levels of the organization
this is exactly what I want I can find
the information I need I don't have to
wait for it you can see some of the
comments that the custom reports really
really useful people have claimed they
got taken 20 minute jobs down to a
minute but I just think it's it's that
the technology the design and the things
that you know Google looker and other
partners around here there's more of
them have brought to bear that allow us
to deliver this for customer so honestly
you can tell I'm excited it's gonna be
fun to roll this out over the next year
my team it's been challenging we've
learned a lot they're not it's not a
smooth road there's a few bumps we've
learned a lot and you will learn a lot
the things changing but but it can be
done and really that was that was our
story for today is that it's out there
it's going out and it does work but that
is really I was gonna I was going to do
a demo but I say I'm running a little
short on time there
these are the partnerships that we've
worked with from here
[Music]